[Music]
spoiler alert Karl cut fit Chandler
when you initially found out that Carl
was bit by a walker what was your
reaction I mean it was kind of the same
reaction I think that everyone had
really just kind of really surprised and
it was unexpected but you know when when
Scott kind of explained it all to me and
it really you know made sense for the
story and for you know for everyone's
characters it kind of made sense for it
to kind of drive the story forward
yeah and kind of take it where the show
is supposed to be going it really took
to be all off the show but you know I
had such a great time like it was really
really awesome you have an eight years I
guess it's definitely an experience that
I don't regret you grew up on our
screens yes essentially you had your
formative years on The Walking Dead take
me back to that first season what do you
remember most so hot that's it yeah at
that quarry it was just ridiculous
yeah no is this the same hat every time
I'm assuming you had multiple hats a
multiple has okay yeah yeah this I
actually I had the same hat from the
second season until like season four or
five and was like this thing is way too
small we can we got it we got it upgrade
and I think actually by season seven or
eight I had like Andy's old hat from
like season one which is pretty cool and
actually when I went to rap they they
gave me like I'm a hat from the first
season that that any war and a like a
science dog t-shirt there were from
season one like frame and everything it
was a really cool cool send-off will you
come back and secretly portray a walker
like some of the other stars oh that
would be awesome yeah that'd be pretty
cool I'd love to do that what kind of a
walker cuz you know we've had well
walkers we've had fence walkers we don't
know the well walker has like been
hands-down my favorite walker no it's
it's so just with the maggots like
crawling out of it in everywhere it's
it's it's so well done and it'd be it'd
be so cool to be a bit like that
would you ever envision that karl could
come back in like a flashback or dream
sequence oh yeah I think it's a possible
yeah
before mom died she told me that I was
gonna beat this world you will